عطله العاصمه السعوديه الرياض متصدره
للمشهد الفني عالميا في حفل اسطوري جوائز
20 23
اكيد نحن العالم عربي واحد وبدعي لك عبر
العربيه انه ااه نعم اوروبا الجديده هي في
الشرق الاوسط وعلى راسها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه نحن عالم واحد نحن بدنا نمبر وان
باذن الله حنكون مثل ما ولي العهد قال ان
شاء الله هذا فخر لنا شكرا على الاشياء
هذه جميله وهمم
قالها مع المستشار تركي ال الشيخ فوق
الخيال احنا قاعد نعيش فوق الخيال هذا
الاحتفاليه اللي انا دائما اقول اي
احتفاليه هي بذره لا لا هذه تمت زراعه
شجره لتصبح مظل الفن لتصبح مركز الفن
بنقول العالم انه مركز الفن القادم من يوم
ورايح هو المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الموسم الثالث
جديده تحت اسم صناع الترفيه الماسيه تم
تقديمها لرئيس مجلس اداره مجموعه ام بي سي
الشيخ وليد الابراهيم
اللي تشوفونه الان في الرياض هو البدايه
بدايه بسيطه جدا العمل مهما كان القياده
مكه واعطه واذا ما في رجال ينفذون على
الارض مثل الرجال هذا اللي قاعد قدامنا
معالي المستشار تركي ال الشيخ
ومثله رجال اخرين اليوم موجودين عملوا عمل
المستحيل وجبار كما تم تكريم فنانين من
حول العالم بجوائز فخريه خاصه بصناعه
الترفيه وجوائز الانجاز مدى الحياه وشخصيه
العام وكان للراحلين نصيب من الحضور في
الحفل رغم غيابهم
[موسيقى]
حصد فيلم كيرا والجن على جائزه الفيلم
المفضل يعني يكسب الجائزه يعني الافلام
كلها حلوه يعني وجودنا هنا هو ده الحاجه
الكويسه
الممثله الافضل والممثل الافضل سينمائيا
للفنانه هند صبري والفنان احمد عز واهم
حاجه ان احنا الاثنين معانا مفتاح البيت
يعني فاللي هي مش هيكسب ااا معه مفتاح
فيما حققت اغنيه شكرا للفنانه اصاله لقب
الاغنيه المفضله كلنا عم نتنافس لحب الناس
يعني هذه اهم شيء وبالنهايه اذا عم نتنافس
بتكون منافسه شريفه لنقدم الافضل للناس
دائما وحققت المطربه الغام لقب الفنانه
ولقب الفنان المفضل ذهب للمطرب عبد المجيد
عبد الله
وجودنا كلنا بيعتبروا نجاح بحد ذاته
وتقدير لا لا لا
لكن الاعمال اللي عم نقدمها
ان شاء الله ما في الاجازه واحده شوف انا
هالايام مغرم يا عبد المجيد مغرم فيك كثير
هالايام مع انه كلهن بيستاهلوا ياخذوه
الحقيقه والله اتوقع عبدالمجيد
والباقين يستاهلون جائزه الوجه الجديد
المفضل موسيقيه كان من نصيب الفنانه جوري
قطان
حسن هتاخذ الجائزه ولا تروح عليك
انا لو قلت هتخرب الدنيا انا اشوف
من الحب فاتمنى
في منانه تعبير الصغير جائزه المؤثره
المفضله وجائزه المؤثر المفضل ذهبت لاحمد
الشقيري لهذا مستوى احترافي عالمي يعني في
تنظيم المهرجانات امانه يعني حضرتنا الاول
حضرت الثاني والان هذا الثالث يعني التوهج
يزيد سنه عن سنه قاعد يزيد التوهج بشكل
فوق التخيل يعني وخطف النجم اشرف حكيمي
جائزه رياضيه المفضله وجائزه الرياضيه
المفضله خطفتها مريم صالح بالله
شكرا جزيلا انا سعيد بتواجد في هذا البلد
ليله خاصه نستمتع فيها انا وعائلتي شكرا
لدعمكم
مسلسل صالون زهره على جائزه المسلسل
المفضل صالون زهره صادق الصباح قاعد يعني
يشتغل شغل يجنن المشاهدين ليش لا والله
بالعكس عشان اسلم المشاهدين
والحقيقه انه الواحد يجرب ينوع بالاعمال
كما حصل على جائزتي الممثله المفضله
والممثل المفضل دميا الفنانه نادين نجيم
والفنان ابراهيم حجاج
ان شاء الله يا رب ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله في رمضان يا رب
انا والله في نصيحه ترى والله مجرد وصول
النهائيات فيني باكيا وجائزه الوجه الجديد
المفضل راميا كانت من نصيب الفنانه هيلدا
ياسين
اكبر
السعوديه للسير على السجاده البنفسجيه في
واحده من ابرز ليالي موسم الرياضه
سعود الخلف العربيه الرياض